un air de déjà vu à boulder dans l'état
du colorado ce lundi à 14h30 heure
locale un homme de 21 ans entre dans un
supermarché
muni d'une arme semi-automatique et y
assassine dix personnes dont un policier
une tuerie qui intervient moins d'une
semaine seulement avant une autre
fusillade
atlanta en géorgie où huit personnes ont
été abattues dans plusieurs salons de
massage asiatique de la ville des
massacres qui ont relancé le débat
récurrent sur la législation des armes à
feu outre atlantique
nous pouvons combler les lacunes de
notre système de vérification des
antécédents notamment la faille de
charleston c'est l'un des meilleurs
outils dont nous disposons actuellement
pour prévenir la violence par armes à
feu
le sénat devrait immédiatement adopté je
le répète le sénat américain j'espère
que certains nous écoutent devrait
immédiatement adopté les deux projets de
loi adopté par la chambre qui comble les
lacunes du système de vérification des
antécédents
ce n'est pas ce ne devrait pas être une
question partisane c'est une question
américaine cela va sauver des vies des
vies américaines et nous devons agir
nous devrions également interdire les
flics d'assaut dans la foulée un voeu
pieux qui date de trois décennies déjà
une modification de la législation sur
le port d'armes à feu doit recueillir le
vote de 60 des 100 élus du sénat où la
majorité démocrate n'est que d'une seule
voix barack obama s'y était déjà cassé
les dents en 2013
quelques mois après la tuerie de l'école
scolaire de new times qui avait coûté la
vie à 27 personnes dont 20 enfants
le prédécesseur de donald trump
disposait pourtant à la chambre haute
américaine d'une majorité bien plus
confortable que celle de joe biden et à
washington
le climat ne semble aujourd'hui guère
propice un rapprochement de circonstance
entre démocrates et républicains
cette audition j'espère ouvrir à une
conversation sur les moyens constitue
fait l'essence est née sur la violence
armée en amérique
si nous considérons le problème auquel
nous sommes confrontés sommes mieux
crise de santé publique
l'amérique s'est réveillé aujourd'hui à
l'issue d'un autre cauchemar stupéfiants
choquant sauvage
mais sans surprise price en accion
l'inaction a rendu cette horreur
complètement prévisible
l'inaction de ce congrès nous rend
complice comme beaucoup d'américains the
cherry mon droit de porter des armes
dans le dialogue sur le contrôle des
armes à feu nous considérons rarement
combien les américains sont unis dans
leur défense et leur jouissance de ce
droit
oui à chaque fois qu'il ya une fusillade
on joue cette ridicule pièce de théâtre
où ce comité se réunit et propose un tas
de lois qui ne ferait rien pour arrêter
ses moeurs le droit de détenir une arme
et sacro-saint aux états unis et
s'oppose régulièrement aux initiatives
diverses qui tentent d'endiguer leur
prolifération
selon le quotidien le denver post à
boulder les armes comme le ruger ar 556
qui a servi ce lundi avait été interdite
par la municipalité en 2018 à la suite
d'une tuerie en floride
mais le 12 mars dernier un juge avait
déclaré cette décision illégale
l'auteur du massacre de lundi avait
acheté son arme seulement quatre jours
plus tard quelques heures après les
fusillades la nra le tout puissant lobby
pro armes diffusé sur twitter une
reproduction du deuxième amendement
depuis le début de l'année plus de 4000
personnes ont été tuées par balles aux
états unis